- You live on a farm, right?
- I do, I do.
- Yeah.
- It's my like childhood dream.
- So what animals do you keep?
What all you got going on?
- We have, we have a donkey.
We have his friends, the pony.
We have Katie this like half thoroughbred,
I don't even know the names of horses.
We have a quarter horse named Herman
who is best friends with Katie, I'm sorry.
We have six goats, too many.
We have three ducks, big mistake,
five chickens, wonderful.
(kelly laughs)
And a birdie cat.
Who's a farm cat.
She's great season at night
when my dog was not a farm animal,
I'm missing somebody, but i don't know.
- I love , you just
described the meaning for it,
it's like a family.
Like you just described like
the characters in a film
like Harven Carmen and
he's friends with the pony.
Yeah. (chuckles)
- There should be a film made of them.
And i should make that happen.
- You should.
- Thank you.
- I love it though.
Animals are, they're calming
and you have a dog that seems to get along
with other animals, can we see that photo?
Can somebody put that up?
- Yeah, he, he.
(kelly chuckles)
- Does he not ever try and
eat them or bite at them or?
- Nope, he will.
If you say off, off, off off like that,
he won't, he will freeze.
- Oh, wow good dog,
yeah, he's so well-trained.
He even does it with
cheeseburgers and pizza.
We have some pictures
of that too (laughs).
- That was a little
harder, that was recently.
And that was a little harder, but no,
you say off enough times he
gives you that weird stare
and then you.
- Is he.
- You let him have it.
- Is he an Australian shepherd?
Is that what kind of dog?
- Yeah a Border Collie Aussie mix.
- Oh, okay, that's Very beautiful.
So beautiful.